we're likely to try out many sorts of
lives before we land finally on the
quiet variety rarely does anyone start
there the kind of life where we try to
be in bed by 10 and are intensely
grateful when nothing's gone
dramatically wrong in the preceding
hours
first we might try out the life of Fame
the sort where we dream that someone
will stop us in a shop or a train and
say aren't you or don't I know you from
that's not a negligible thrill
especially if you didn't feel too
noticed in childhood or if in
adolescence it was always someone else
who was able to make people you loved
smile
or we might be drawn to the life of
melodramatic relationships the kind
where we're constantly wondering whether
they love us or we love them where we
break up every couple of weeks and are
calling them frantically to come back
from their parents house and we didn't
mean all those crazy words we said we
were just scared
it can take a lot of pain before we make
our peace with so-called ordinariness
and accept it for the Wonder it is
before we can deeply love a day when we
have nothing to do other than wake up
early finish the dishes from last night
shower read a few poems answer some
emails maybe go to the museum to see
some African masks or a canoe from
Oceania buy some bread fry some eggs we
might become rather Fierce at anyone and
anything that threatens this hard-worn
achievement at well-meaning people who
invite us on complicated excursions or
worrying parties at newspapers that
Force us to think about driven types
starting companies and releasing a new
film or a record we know how much these
stimulants can cost us it takes great
confidence to give up on being special
it takes kindness to oneself to
interrupt the longing for suffering and
anguish one might have needed to try out
almost everything else before realizing
in the end that it was calm we always
really wanted